don't be fooled by these gentle waves
these still waters hide a 20 million
year death match between two prehistoric
monsters
grab some popcorn and a snorkel
you have a front row seat for the
ultimate aquatic showdown
between the megalodon shark
and the leviathan whale
which would have the bigger bite
how big could a megalodon grow
and how fast could a leviathan whale
swim
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the megalodon shark fought the
leviathan whale
20 million years ago these creatures
dominated the oceans and they may have
fought before that
although they're long gone you can still
see the remains of these giants in their
descendants
just look at the sperm whale which
descended from its toothed ancestor
even this monster doesn't compare in
size to the leviathan
and while you might think that the great
white descended from the megalodon
it's closer to the blue shark
see that snubbed nose and flat jaw
but if we could see these two giants
face off now
who would win
enjoying this fight want some more
action
step into the ring and subscribe to our
new channel versus
who would win in a fight a mongoose or a
cobra liquid nitrogen or lava a
saber-toothed tiger or a massive holy
mammoth we'll break down each fight and
see who takes the crown click on the
link below to find out
okay before we get to the main event
let's run down the stats on these
fighters
the leviathan whale grew to almost 18
and a half meters in length in its
heyday
while today's sperm whale relies on
suction to lure its prey
this monster had teeth the size of
bowling pins to rip its males apart
its massive mouth had the largest
tetrapod bite recorded
and it fed on other whales
but these teeth were not this killer's
only weapon
some scientists theorized that the sperm
whale uses its unique organ
the spermacetta to control its buoyancy
during deep dives
the waxy substance inside hardens and
lets the whale sink into the water
easier by filling this body part with
cold water
but since the leviathan didn't hunt deep
sea creatures
researchers think that this organ could
have been used as a battering ram to
hammer prey into submission
scientists also wonder if this organ
could have increased the whale's
echolocation ability
that means a leviathan could have
stunned its target with a sonic blast
but
how would the megalodon handle this
powerhouse
well don't count out this predator yet
tests have dated megalodon shark fossils
back two and a half million years
and the largest bones found were almost
18 meters long
making this the largest fish to ever
roam the seas
this shark had one of the most powerful
bite forces of any predator on earth
and with 276
serrated teeth that measured almost 18
centimeters long
this terror has earned its fearsome
reputation
like the leviathans megalodons fed on
large whales sharks and dolphins
these gigantic creatures were so fierce
that some theories state their babies
would devour each other alive while
still developing in their mothers
but you didn't come here for baby shark
let's get to the main event
weighing in at almost 60 tons
the megalodon would outweigh the
leviathan
the shark might have seen the whale
first while on patrol giving it ample
opportunity to attack first
while the whale comes in at only 45 tons
this killing machine is much more
intelligent than its opponent and could
try different tactics
if the leviathan had used its agile
swimming maneuvers to get at just the
right angle its sonic boom could stun
the megalodon
then the whale could ram the massive
shark with its head
but this warm-blooded mammal couldn't
stay underwater forever
it had to come up for air
that could give the megalodon the
opportunity to chase its deadly prey
speeding along at 17 meters per second
this ancient shark could have cut
through the water fast and landed a bite
on the leviathan's fin making the whale
all but helpless
if the meg caught a hold of the fin
it could tear through the whale like a
steel trap
remember this predator relied only on
instinct and sheer power and unlike the
leviathan
it did not back down
but if the whale
managed to bite the shark's soft
underbelly
it could have a chance of tearing apart
its spine
with a bite superior to the megalodons
a few strategic whale chomps would end
this fight once and for all
while most people online give this fight
to the megalodon shark
the leviathan whale has the speed and
wits to come out on top
what about you
who do you think would win this battle
let us know in the comments
now this fight was the warm-up
next up we have the gigantasaurus
versus the troadon
get to your corners because
that's a story
for another
what if